i have been a photographer for national
geographic for
27 years now i think something like that
i think i had i had hair
back when i started um i might even
still have those bell-bottom pants i was
wearing uh when i was a young turk
photographer back in that in the day i
can hear the question coming and some
one of the the couple will ask
so
you take all these pictures and i said
yes i do
and then they say
do you actually go
i'm not kidding they do this do you
actually go to all the places you
photograph and i have to say yes that's
the way it works actually yes it is
i was fascinated when i found out that
they had their tomato day coming up at
seed savers because all of a sudden they
were going to have like 47 varieties of
tomatoes laid out and they were going to
have all these people going through now
this is photographer heaven when you're
doing a story like this because
somebody's actually going to be doing
something and here were all these people
going through there
tasting 47 varieties i i actually i hoop
and haul are in the office my wife gets
used to this i'm over there doing
research on trying to figure out how to
photograph a story like this you see and
i'll get off the phone having learned
that they would have tomato day you know
man i'm i'm thrilled that this is big
time stuff folks you know i love it
yeah so here you know there's just these
little kind of everyday life things are
going to happen in front of me you know
these cattle who have been around
hanging around with for 10 000 years
have become part of the family really
you know i mean these i like these guys
standing there with the cows and i can't
tell who's happier you know they're all
just there at the fair and they're
having a great time you know and they're
showing off everybody's showing off you
know and they're just they just love it
you know
we're out there our partnership with
horses out there here i am at the under
windmill up in the sand hills nebraska
and they're coming in from branding and
they've all gathered around for a little
moment and the horses are sharing the
water and you know that the horses feel
good
and we feel good and we feel good in
this this partnership we have developed
as a species in partnership with these
animals and they are very close to us
goats for 9 000 years
there are all kinds of species for
instance photographers we've only been
domesticated for about 150 years
and we're not fully domesticated yet so
you know don't let us into the living
room okay yeah
derbyshire red cap
look at that comb on this guy he's you
know he you could just tell when he
walked around you know he's a proud guy
you know he really likes strutting his
his stuff this is the glamorous life of
a photographer
back in some back barn you know where we
can find it you know but i was assisted
by the chicken whisperers jim and the
guy there at the farm you know
and and uh and jim got really good you
know you can take it put your finger
right underneath the chicken's chin like
this you know and and just raise it up
and the chicken will go
and they'll and then you go
and they stay there for just a second
you know this is the kind of stuff we
learned to do you know
[Music]
you